in the opening of the original Final
Fantasy seven Cloud Strife
and an eco-terrorist cell named
avalanche blow up a reactor that reactor
is siphoning an energy called maca from
the planet and using it to power a
sprawling industrial metropolis called
Midgar the group infiltrates fights off
Shinra Electric Company's forces and
sets off the explosion destroying the
reactor from there it's a hop skip and
jump through a few sections of the city
back to the safety of avalanches hideout
in Final Fantasy 7 remake however you
walk through the streets in the
aftermath and see the harrowing
consequences of your choices it asks you
to question whether you're doing the
right thing by joining this so-called
group of freedom fighters just to make a
quick buck Final Fantasy 7 remake
opening bombing mission is a clear and
powerful statement of intent the game
may just be the first chapter of the
originals much bigger story but a
uncovers depth that had been left to the
imagination it's rich in details that
were previously unexplored realizes new
storytelling ambitions with confidence
and presents fresh perspectives that
feel essential it does all this so
successfully that it's hard to think
that this story existed in any other way
it's important to know that yes I have
history with Final Fantasy 7 I'm a fan
but this isn't a game that pandas to
fans newcomers can also enjoy the
majesty of Midgar and learn to love
characters for the first time or while
playing a mechanically dense and
rewarding role-playing game even if it's
just a piece of the original Final
Fantasy 7 this remake takes one of the
most beloved games of all time and
elevates it higher
[Music]
remix gameplay feels modern but is
crystallized around the classics
role-playing fundamentals its gameplay
model feels like the culmination of the
franchise's evolution a composite of
ideas that combines into something fresh
but familiar this is the first time that
the action-focused Isle of the modern
era of Final Fantasy games doesn't feel
like it comes at the expense of the
methodical nature of the series's roots
the hybrid style lets you glide between
characters at the touch of a button and
assume direct control at the same time
commands can be issued to characters our
otherwise acting independently conjuring
the spirit of that deliberate stand in
place and fight former of old the remake
uses an active time bar to govern
special abilities spells and item uses
to encourage juggling of party members
ATB bars feel much more rapidly when you
take control of the character and attack
the enemy directly and characters tend
not to use the more advanced skills of
their own volition so it's super
important that you step in and put their
resources to good use each playable
character also has a unique skill that
comes at no cost and has a great deal of
strategic value characters can also use
various offensive and defensive magical
spells provided they have the materia
that bestows is the ability to them
material was and still is the core of
Final Fantasy sevens gameplay the beauty
of the materia system is that it allows
you to create loadouts in a very
freeform way and build characters to fit
your preferred style or strategy for any
situation although each playable
character has a general archetype
materia system presents a great deal of
fluidity within this so even your
long-range fire can play a support
magician if you want
the demands of moment-to-moment combat
are high especially since enemies can be
vicious if you're not careful they will
poison and paralyze to create openings
for each other make areas of the
battlefield deadly to limit your
movement and pounce on a character to
trap them forcing you to switch
characters to free your ensnare party
member most enemies have some sort of
elemental weakness that can be
identified and then exploit if you do
this then become pressured and
eventually staggered leaving them
completely defenseless enemies can also
interrupt your actions or move out of
the way entirely to evade you so precise
timing is also crucial thankfully when
issuing commands the action slows to a
crawl to give you breathing room this
won't save you if your plan is
ill-considered though so you've got to
be small
on occasion particularly in tightest
spaces the camera can struggle to keep
up with the action but it's not often
enough to be a serious problem as a
whole the combat has the fluidity as
well as the cinematic and visually
stunning flare of modern Final Fantasy
games but also the satisfaction of the
plan your work and work your plan
approach of the classics add-on the
upgrading mechanics which allow you to
spend points on each weapon to bolster
attributes and you've got a robust
interconnected set of RPG mechanics I
can confidently say that Final Fantasy
has never felt this good to play
for a strongest Final Fantasy 7 remake
gameplay is it's the narrative and the
characters that truly stand out as its
crowning achievement for the vast
majority of the game Final Fantasy 7
remake is a focused deeply personal
story even though avalanches ultimate
goal is to free the planet from the
vampiric jaws of Shinra the events that
transpire narrowed that battle down to a
struggle for the here and the now
instead of the future unlike the
original there's also a much greater
emphasis on the moral gray areas of the
bowel avalanche essentially pokes the
sleeping dragon and when Shinra
retaliates
it's the already downtrodden people of
the slums that suffer they live a meager
existence albeit one they're comfortable
with as citizens of the undersea living
in the squalor of homes built from
rusted metal sheets propped up and
forced together is all they've known and
all they've known has been provided by
Shinra because of that many don't see
avalanches fight against Shinra as a
clear-cut battle between good and evil
in the same way that Barret or other
members of avalanche do we will not
submit to intimidation or violence but
work together for peace and prosperity
that is how civilized people change the
world
[Music]
that is the Xinhua freeze there's
fighting words in multiple chapters
remix slows the pace down so you can
spend time in the slums meet the people
there understand their daily plates and
get involved with the community this is
done through optional side-quests that
provides some sort of valuable world
building or an opportunity to understand
another person a little more
mechanically side missions are usually
simple go here kill the enemy talk to a
person or get an item and then return
jobs but there's always a little story
to be told that pulls you deeper into
their world and each one also humanizes
cloud just a little
[Music]
I'll do it for three Gil I'm offering a
special discount right now on toad king
Jack's looks like it's your lucky day as
an ex-soldier turned merc he begins
taking on odd jobs to make money but as
he completes these word of him spreads
and he becomes a champion of the people
whether he likes it or not this not only
chips away at clouds hard edges but
makes you as the player invest in the
world around you and the people within
it Final Fantasy 7 remake is the story
of Cloud Strife learning to fight for
others instead of just himself how comes
the hard part
characters that were formerly relegated
to bit pods are given more depth so you
learn more about avalanche members like
Biggs wedge and Jesse among many others
there are poignant and personal moments
with them that are delivered through
heartfelt lines of dialogue it all feels
natural believable and relatable there's
so much texture in these characters
which makes them easy to connect with
without spoiling anything remake also
pause in characters from the extended
fiction of Final Fantasy 7 and these new
additions for in naturally it feels like
scoring Linux isn't remaking Final
Fantasy 7 it's rebuilding the larger
Final Fantasy 7 universe some odd jobs
that you undertake will have you working
alongside key characters like Tifa and
Arif for the former the game elegantly
establishes her history with cloud with
frightening glimpses at their traumatic
past appearing as intrusive flashes
there are the result of some damaged
part of cloud psyche this mechanism is
also used to weave in the presence of a
certain silver haired villain in a way
that didn't happen in the original the
rapport between cloud and Tifa is
depicted so well their friends who
support each other but there's also a
blossoming romance that builds as cloud
recalls their history together and what
she means to him
Aerith the flower girl whose story
unexpectedly intersexual clouds is
beyond an uplifting presence the banter
between her and cloud is sweet and funny
from the moment you meet her she pokes
at his ego and begins tearing down his
walls he's playful and
for them an effortlessly endearing you
did it yeah all right good enough let's
keep on trucking all the characters feel
like real people they have hopes and
dreams fears and faults they're funny
and charismatic and so well written and
acted that you'll fall for every single
one of them when playing the original
these were all thoughts and feelings I
had about the coders that I colored in
myself using the outlines that game
presented this time they're not
illusions it's all painstakingly
realized and as much as I love the
characters and stories back then I'm
able to appreciate them in a much more
profound way because of how complete it
all feels now there's so much to
Marvella in the remake and it doesn't
shy away from embracing the goofy
elements of the original instead using
it to bring levity to what is otherwise
heavy subject matter even as the game
reaches its conclusion and embraces the
more outlandish and fantastical parts of
the story it does so in a way that feels
earned again this might just be a small
chunk of the original release but as a
standalone game Final Fantasy 7 remake
is a complete package although a great
villain lingers in the periphery of the
story cryptically alluding to something
more in clouds past and unexplained
elements are introduced in its
conclusion this doesn't diminish the
story that is told regardless of your
history with the original game Final
Fantasy 7 remake is an astounding
achievement the wait for the release was
long but in gameplay story characters
and music it delivers the weight was
worth it for first-time players it's an
opportunity to understand why Final
Fantasy 7 is held in such high regard
it's the chance to experience a
multi-faceted story that grapples with
complex subject matter be in the company
of memorable characters and be moved by
their plight for returning fans this
isn't the Final Fantasy 7 your mind
remembers it's the one your heart always
knew it to be
[Music]